what is up everyone Anna Mack here for
anime uproar welcome to another episode
of rent cafe episode 42 I believe by my
counsel we've been at this for a while
joining me today we have a very special
guest for the first time here on the
channel misty /khroe Mexia what is up
misty
Hey thank you for having me it's a great
pleasure to join you guys then tell you
about all these cool stuff that
yesterday also man glad that you could
join us you're friends with our boy Knox
talker and glad that you guys could
figure things out figure out a schedule
to make it to the stream it's gonna be a
lot of fun we also have Knox Taku back
what's up Knox nothing much great I'm
glad to be back every week is a pleasure
very nice a general statement but it
brings it all together by the way we
also have anime recon in the building
what's up anime read what is up i'm hype
for this year let's go and hey recon
back in the UK so he's gonna be extra
hyped up and crazy tonight and we also
got soul maka also in the UK yeah what's
up Lamont see boy here again always glad
to be here nice
thanks guys everyone for joining me
welcome everyone in the chat I see
people are chilling the chat and talking
already for a general topic that we're
gonna have this week is long anime or
long Shonen and whether they're worth
your time because as you guys know I've
been a pretty big skeptic of long anime
meaning anime over a hundred episodes
usually you know my type favorite types
or anime are like Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood around 60 episodes so I'm
I've been very hesitant even though I've
seen a ton of anime to watch long anime
however lately I've been hearing more
and more that people are recommending
and especially I know my brother Gozen
is really into one piece right now he's
reading the whole manga trying to catch
up 1 over 100 episode anime that I did
recently catch up on is Dragon Ball
super which I was a huge fan of Dragon
Ball Z as
kid but then I've been putting off
during Apple super for such a long time
and then I finally caught up to it but
there's a ton of other anime that I have
it so I'm looking here to be convinced
about why anime over 100 episodes are
worth our time in the chat guys let me
know what you think about any over
hundred so who wants to take it away
first in this discussion sure though
mine um a bunch of anime that are over a
hundred episodes long that I am really
fond of one of them would be hunter
hunter 2011 the new version that made
that was made by perhaps it was
absolutely stunning when it came out and
it also ran to catch up to where the
manga was and then there's a giant
pissing contests of on itis off I ate is
so it kind of isn't going anywhere but
hopefully the the enemy by itself I I
consider is is a good standalone one
that you can watch at your leisure
yeah I've heard a lot about when I'm
actually I've seen like the first 30
episodes or something like that first
training arc or like I know exam exam
arc right again but I was actually
watching it in French misty because I
practice French I'm trying to learn
French perfecting and on Netflix France
which I got totally legally are you can
you have it conduct with French
subtitles so I like having the subtitles
and the pubs there I was watching that
for the first 30 episodes of in they ran
out of episodes they don't have anymore
and then I kind of dropped it but a lot
of people haven't telling me to pick it
back up so that is the flame good one I
saw lemaster I'll suggest it in the chat
knocks well once we're once we're
talking about hunter hunter I have a
question for misty yes you mentioned
that your favorite character is gone and
he's the only thing I don't like in
Hunter hunter that's what I said yes I'm
pretty sure my favorite character in
Hunter hunter was iske the clown yeah
well when we were at otaku thon you
mentioned it was gone and your wife said
what about Hisoka the clown guy yes well
the thing is like unlike
because the thing I like about Gandhi
mouse is very spoilery it's later on
with them if an ant ark yes yes I really
like how he is psychology
well how his psyche can turn and I think
that really makes him a deep character
in the long run but when he starts he's
kind of flat a little bit no I think
he's flat the whole way until you know
he gets obsessed with something and then
he sort of you know he does a total 180
and stays like a 180 until the end of
the arc no no he was my one issue with
the show but yeah Hisoka is the best
character in my opinion the other thing
I kind of liked about Gunn is his
special move they're a rock paper
scissor
yeah that's iconic yeah the master of
using weird-ass crap in cool ways I mean
they have knives and knives are useless
but then someone comes with yo-yos and
fishing rods and that's gonna destroy
the competition I know and a thing that
I really liked about the whole hunter
hunter is the dodgeball match oh that
was amazing Hisoka yeah I mean the whole
thing yeah just a whole like punching
the ball was just fun in itself it had
such a good potential builder yeah
someone asked me for a Sports anime once
is a hunter hunter yeah see I assume you
guys are talking about gone because
that's all I know I'm since I walked
into French but at first I wasn't that
into the him I'm like he seems kind of
like an ash Ketcham type character am I
wrong here he starts up like one you
know eventually he becomes a little bit
more than that okay so its development
things yeah much like ash cuz ash pretty
much sucks throughout the anime and gone
is always good for wherever he is he's
on a decently high level mm-hmm okay
yeah yeah also kilowatt it is that how
you pronounce that I don't know kilowatt
yeah yeah yeah yeah he to me seems a
cool guy except that he saw all
at such a young age that to me I was
kind of like come on you know yeah but
he has the back story to back it up so I
mean he has the back story and he's
equally powerful to gun he's not that
much yeah
the gun is yeah they're pretty even
they're even throughout the only thing I
had an issue with kilowatt is his
progression throughout the story was
completely contingent on gone yeah he's
my friend so I'll follow him around he
didn't really have his own umph yeah but
do you really need to have them like
have a purpose I mean you just want to
hang out and just not be with his family
which kind of sex I'm like given what
these families like it makes sense you
know yeah it's quite the badass though
yeah I like to call it he was my
favorite I mean I actually preferred
karateka though to kill OA because this
always has to keep I basket was based
off him kind of yeah you know it also
comes back to just like vengeance and
killing people because you want them
dead but it just never really led to
anything I mean he did eventually fight
one of the spider but after has just got
yo most they're like in that hole when
killer goes home wasn't there like a
weird like sex torture scene with his
mom or something or am I remember this
wrong this family's pretty [ __ ] up
yeah yeah yeah I was like what cuz like
on the one hand I'm getting the Ash
Ketchum
wide from going he has like a fishing
rod [ __ ] like that and then on the other
hand you voted like that torture house
where he lives and it's like coming from
you that you don't like the mother and
son sex torture scene but kill kill a
kill is the best thing ever
yes I love misty your thoughts on killa
kill I know it's not a long Shonen but
me and Knox have been at it for a while
I love it I love it he doesn't like it I
like what it stands for as for an edgy
enemy that has an actual story and
it has also got a particular art style
that really for the time it came out it
was pretty well but now would the the
hall drawback it kind of it doesn't
really age all that well I feel it's it
for for the people who enjoyed it it was
really when it came out it was a
revelation now it kind of got forgotten
by a lot of people yeah for me if I love
the whole continent it's so edgy but
it's like actually for a reason because
there's a purpose and for that I give it
points this is the thing with edgy
I hate when it's just fanservice that's
just splattered on the screen to just
like please the fans and there's no
story going on that's that's why I I
appreciate I scold the XD there's an
actual plot that's like wrapped up
around it or even if it's just comedy
there's just like so many shows that
just have those giant streaks of light
to just butchered the whole anime I'm
like come on guys yeah I like I like
actually I like fanservice but it has to
be classy yeah what I mean by that is
like it with cooking guru II like they
just have random panty shots just like
you know they're walking and also the
camera is like underneath looking at the
pennies it's like how would you as you
know the protagonist or whoever your
perspective it's thinking how would you
ever see that angle it's like it's not
realistic whereas it's the reason they
need to have less clothing because the
more clothing you have the more likely
the clothing is gonna take people over
right so it's like we need less as
little clothing as possible and it's
hilarious and then I also have this
whole philosophical thing about Kayla
kill him by the way Jonathan ex Essex
just finished it in the chatty says and
he liked it so he's on my side knocks
but I love the concept of you know colds
meaning fashion what others think of us
kind of thing ilysm taking over the
world like the philosophical kind of
concept and then nudist beach the guys
they are kind of rejecting that are kind
of reckon repelling against what I think
a lot of it represents modern society
and how we've come to only look at
ourselves based on what others think of
us based on I
Rousseau my favorite foster calls it a
move pork more propria which is this
love of self that only depends on how
others see you so you know if you if
others think in grade than you think
you're great but if others think you
suck then you think you soft right you
don't have your own self-confidence and
clothes is a huge symbol of that right
because it's like the most outward thing
you wear where you kind of feel showing
off it's like look at me I'm fashionable
I'm trendy that kind of things so I feel
like there's like a dimension there to
kill a kill a philosophical one that I
really enjoy so Knox how does it feel
being wrong feels great to be right he
said it was a good edgy and me I stand
by that
good edgy anime I'm come to wait guys
good stay that way you've been talking
about hunter hunter for the past ten
minutes I'm like no I watched hunter
hunter I haven't even [ __ ] watched it
and to be honest I'm gonna do it even
what what long like Shonen anime have
you watched though to be honest very one
I did was Fairy Tail okay he said he
wanted to talk about Fairy Tail in this
come on I'm pretty sure some people here
have watched very time I think not i
watch very you know yeah
misty did you watch Fairy Tail I did all
of it no I dropped the dropped around I
think it was a lightning guy that's it
it was about like maybe it was it was
like six openings in I missed a point in
the new misty role Rico I think he gave
it up fears at all
like some people three Episode rule and
some people give it to 70 episodes oh I
watched fair and Talib also watch the
embrace Deep Freeze was amazing and most
my favorite arc in fairy tale was when
all the guilds were battling in the
arena that was probably my most favorite
tournament the tournament are yeah now
my favorite heart I don't know my
biggest piss off about fairy gel here's
a general a general scenario right all
four main character Natsu Lucy gray Ursa
fight a bad guy they lose
that's who fight the same bad guy he
wins the [ __ ] how four versus one you
lose and then one versus one you finally
win no I'll explain to you it's because
at the end of every Nakhimov at the end
of every arc they Natsu some ether-nano
bullcrap that makes him insanely
overpowered for like 10 it's a bad guy
and then lose all his power so the next
arc he can get his ass kicked by Ursa
again yeah well we call that French
Annette with her there's only one reason
towards all your questions and because
he has the blood of a dragon that's
right
he is so also be like a cannibal yeah he
beat like the mightiest dragon he beat a
bunch of dragons Natsu he did not beat
acta logia he got do you know no he
destroy my he didn't manga I'm pretty
sure he's not gonna read the manga no
people have been telling me that Natsu
did be him in a manga so I'm not so yeah
you beat him Natsu also lights time on
fire in the manga okay this is very kid
well I'm just saying my opinion I think
Fairy Tail is good I haven't yet watched
dragon cry because I cannot find it
anywhere and we all know yeah yeah I
know it's not out online yeah but we all
know Fairy Tail is coming to end well it
already ended the manga but um the new
season is still yet to air and then boom
I heard they're doing a reboot of it
well we'll see how it comes bomb I'm
quite sad that's gonna end
dammit recon didn't you watch Misty's
video where he tells you not to watch
anime illegally online I don't know well
I do watch a ton crunchyroll but where
am I supposed to watch dragon cry come
on man I have crunchyroll now and then
gotta wait until the DVD comes out yeah
which is useless I have that we have the
Amazon Prime and here in Canada we
actually get the Amazon animes stuff
just by having Prime you don't have to
pay extra so I haven't that well yeah
there's definitely some anime out there
they're still not available which sucks
so madness in the chat with some bro
also we had um who wasn't someone said
in the chat that they got like nine
episodes into fairytale I got like 30
episodes into it it was the same deal
with the French like with hunter hunter
for me but yeah like what to me off I
enjoy the characters like I like as I
like Lucy they're interesting has that
best girl you like the Lucy
yeah like the first letter
she's like one that has kind of some
flavor and death to it where she doesn't
comes up how to get like very powerful
because everybody else is like super
Opie in the beginning what she has a
good backstory backstory she was in this
slave camp thing and literally every arc
for like three four arcs in a row she
meets old prisoners from that slave camp
that's all in one up and she turns them
good by the end of the arc yeah what
about our friendship our friendship
fairy tale you know flaunts that power
of friendship a lot cuz there are no bad
guys that remain bad by the end of the
series except the demons who they kill
everyone else becomes good mm-hmm
yeah it was hell vien by the way who
said he got nine episodes in you had the
thing that threw me off about fairy tale
even where I where I was that is the
whole spirit realm or whatever where
like no one actually dies they just go
into like they become Lucy's spirits or
something
well that's me that's my goodness right
with Shonen is a lot of shows refused to
kill characters they just put it on the
back burner and then they come back so
you end up with a cast of like over a
hundred 200 AB characters that you just
lose track of who's who and what power
if someone has like one piece is guilty
I had narratives guilty of that bleach
was family guilty of that and then
that's why they're really like a hunter
hunter there's there's not that many
characters I mean there's the this fire
troop which is the the bad guys and then
there's gun Kilwa laurio a little bit
and could I become that's about it I
mean besides that there's some people at
the very beginning but they don't really
stay in the story well yeah and as far
as Naruto they actually have the balls
to kill some characters but don't worry
they all come back
yeah was it us Asuma and Jorah and never
came back
Jiraiya did not and dry I probably will
somewhere in boards oh they'll find a
way to bring him back
don't worry yeah I kind of feel like
that to you awesome I didn't come back
he's dead too
he fought Shikamaru yeah you mean the
Edo yeah you cool you call it Edo coming
back yeah yeah it's the same character
they either get stopped so all the Ito's
died okay stop a little army of zetsu's
to sacrifice and you bring everyone back
yeah well yeah this is why guys this is
why my favorite anime is good and lagann
no problem with killing people in that
show so yeah I think I love that show
but think again like a shorter anime so
I the longer and I may have not been
something that I've been really into
myself
I've got about good good long anime had
you may know hippo yeah season was 75
episodes then we are 2 OVA s then we are
226 episode seasons yes yeah do you
think there's a movie as well yeah I
think so but yeah yeah Jonas which one
is champion road is that the movie Orson
is one of the series yeah that's one of
the movies after the first season yeah
[Music]
yes yeah yeah yeah my brother again he
loves it but I'm not sports because
haikyuu is number one has ever seen
that's not saying a lot that's based on
scene I've seen others I've seen cage oh
I've seen Kuroko no basket which I
dropped because it did sucked slam dunk
did you saw Prince of tennis did you see
I still 21 you see all the drives you
want machine at all yeah it was all
right
misty what are your favorite sports
enemy did you like them a lot my
favorite would be I feel 21 and then
decides that I really like slam dunk
I like Prince of tennis overdrive is one
of my favorite it's pretty shorts 26
episodes
baby steps is good I think I'm too much
sold on Prince of tennis to enjoy baby
step so much I think it was kind of
dirty versus Prince of tennis said
already did my thing is I'm actually
seeing believe it or not more classical
music anime than like Sports anime
classical music did you see like Cour
d'Honneur oh no but I've seen Nodame
cantabile I've seen your line April and
April have seen
another one that was older did I forget
the name now coming to know Apollo yeah
it's low yes yes that's kind of classic
but also jazz I suppose but yeah like I
probably have seen more music and
classical music I've been going to the
Sports Center which is kind of weird
when you think about how many sports
anime are out there you should check out
like or dad or oh it's it's kind of a
reverse harem but uh the music is so
good in it okay seemed Fuuka Fuuka
making noise who does not counted as a
music anime well hookahs about a guy who
really counts like saying to Zuka as a
sports enemy all right how about hookah
making noise that's the music enemy I
don't know if you guys have watched it
yeah well it doesn't you know but
Suzuki's close to the sports on tomato
it's right it's not really about likes
sports all that much it's a romance
story with a sports theme around it did
you see one else awesomeness no I didn't
see one out no I have to say that's
probably my favorite sports anime what
out is really good if you like def note
it's kind of the same kind of
psychological with enemy yeah it's what
it's on my list the definite video
coming up yeah oh man one it's 26
episodes
have you watched all out the rugby anime
yes I was a baseball no yeah 1 ounces
baseball but all out is rugby yes it was
a huge cast of characters that nut that
didn't develop at all
yeah that's this problem I had the main
character did I mean he was he was kind
of a new one he started but then he
started getting better at the game
that's character development for you
you know development that's getting
stronger on your on your Death Note
look-alike enemy did you put ultimate
survivor kg I did yeah I know you game
yeah basically this is how it works
misty anything I watched anything I
recommend those guys here just gonna
stay away from it because they think I
have died yeah you get shit-faced man
sorry you don't understand he put out
like five top ten lists in a row
recommending testament to the sister new
devil Noriko oh boy you men I love you
like I was enjoying one of his ten list
it was about the best new romance anime
and then I see era manga sensei and I'm
like [ __ ] oh yeah his top romances of
all time he has like toradora
golden time and whatever and number one
was hajimeta no Gow no shut up oh no not
old time I didn't say old time
well she calls them all all time but he
makes like parts twos and threes well I
did include has original gallows my
number one spot yeah above like you're
lying in April cannot up stories the
best don't even trigger me guys misty
what do you think of hazard maternal
girl this is garbage
thank a salute trash with those labs
that only their boobs can give them some
death which was okay which is okay
but I dropped it because of the whole
lolicon crap the big fat guy is like the
thing that ruins me to know God because
he's just so into perfection yeah
other than that's perfection but that
big guy if he was not in the series then
the whole thing would be perfection it's
so bad okay let's move on to more along
Conan I just want to say gray wolf says
lost a lot from Serbia yeah my Serbian
brother I'm from Serbia - originally now
living in Ontario but yeah not to you my
friend yes knocks continue ok so for a
long-running ich schon an anime that I
would like an animatic to watch
specifically you have any guesses Jojo
that is a long-running Shonen it has
over 100 deficits
like 113 by now or something something
like that yeah yeah like I have never
gotten into JoJo's and knocks cannot get
over that he judge oh is a really it's a
style that you really need to be curious
about to get into it otherwise he'll
you'll see it as kind of ludicrous and a
little bit over-the-top
well I'd riggers so is it anything like
killer killer it's mostly have you seen
Fist of the North Star probably not yeah
I know of it I haven't seen the whole
thing but yes I know it's kind of the
same level of manliness where it's all
about like guys being manly and it blood
all the epic battles and eventually it
becomes something else entirely but for
for the first few season like I i'd
suggest like watching the very first
season cuz that by itself is a good
spend alone if you don't want to watch
the whole thing at least like the 2012
remake that he is a really good point to
start on and then after watching the
first season you can decide whether or
not you like it enough to keep going but
yeah you have to be careful there
because the first part of the phantom
blood arc you know the first part of
JoJo's is a little slow and is not that
great
and the second part okay maybe it just
took me time to get into it because once
if you can go in there with an open mind
and say to yourself these people will
push normality to the limits and it will
be awesome then you will have the best
time of your life and the battles and
JoJo's trumps anything in almost any
other anime I say almost hesitantly
because I think it's the best battle
anime out there because every stand is
totally different and as totally
different abilities and as long as you
know what it is you have such an edge on
your opponents to work out a way to beat
it if you don't know what your enemy
stand is it could be the weakest thing
on the planet and it will be a
destructive force so you're talking
about from season 3 on once then yeah
I'm talking about episode 25 onwards
okay okay to love room it's all my
management - series would you count
psyche is a long-running Shonen because
there's 120 episodes even though every
episode is only five minutes long I mean
technically yeah okay so psyche was also
awesomeness yes but it's also one of the
shows from national named Jem still
they're rarely miss the mark when it
comes back yes when it comes to Jojo the
starlet Jojo is weird like first but
first the first season is like your main
characters like Jesus very nice person
always going to care for like others and
stuff even to the point of his turning
enemies good he's given them back like
life and stuff you know making them be
able to feel pain and stuff and then the
tone of the show shifts with the second
season because then your hero's more of
a jokester and then that morph it's the
complete style of the show for me at
least anyway because the first show it
felt like okay we're trying to be
serious but then wacky things kept on
happening or oval reactions to things
don't happen and it just kept like
pulling me out yeah I mean but then with
the second generation that that MC morph
it's because he's more joking with it
so then the outrageous stuff that's
going on like gels better together and
then when we've got you know like third
season with him being more like serious
and manly in it it felt like killa kill
did fist and an off stuff that's what I
I don't know the point of JoJo's is
every arc follows a different Jojo and
is slightly you know the whole I the
whole point of the show is slightly
changed you know perspective depending
on who the Jojo is and Jotaro who is the
third Jojo who you're talking about and
I don't think you watch the whole
starters Crusaders so I don't think I am
which do you haven't watched it at all
and you're already complaining how it's
killing
became tonight yeah yeah yeah because
I've seen finish the whole start is true
Saders you tell me United again okay
because I'm pretty sure that Johto is my
favorite Jojo despite Joseph being
awesome as well the only reason you took
it as the criticism is because you don't
like kill the kill
how can you compare them alright then
you're wrong
JoJo's not an edgy alright anyways
no that's good misty that you said that
like you can look at the first season
it's kind of like a standalone and then
see if you're into it I'll definitely
give that a shot I know like I never
watched Legend of Korra because I heard
that it turned into a disaster what my
brother watched the first season I need
to end the movie watch the rest he
dropped it but he's like if you just
watch the first season has come like a
standalone it's good but then it just
don't watch on so yeah sometimes that
happens with anime and non anime
how about Gundam yes it's not Shonen
what about gun it doesn't all have to be
sewn it just your Gundam is it right
again no I don't think they're always
teenagers so I feel like it's a showdown
nah Gundam 0 0 is is like seinen ok yeah
but like most Gundams like I know and
Gundam double-o happens to my favorite
Gundam that I can iron what an orphan
system your blood or friends Gundam see
they have to be like shown and
technically I feel like yeah iron bundle
friend sounds like teenagers but the
point is yeah are there any actual
Gundam series at over 100 episodes no no
but the Gundam franchise camp is but I
wouldn't put it as they like even even
the are in blood at the orphans it's not
technically considered it's because no
it's not it's an action with maybe
teenager in it but being a teenager
doesn't make it play is showing your
default I'm looking through the Gundams
almost none of them are shown ins yeah
no none of them are
the thing shown in right because they're
definitely not like your classic battles
shown in like your non results right but
some people to find shown and only based
on what audience it's geared towards so
they would have given them well
Gundam is not geared towards teenagers
the way I understand Gundam is it's a
different setting for a political story
every Gundam has its own political
issues that they're dealing with and
that's the focus as opposed to the
protagonist developing you know Super
Saiyan Quincy hollow tailed beast form
one thing I liked about the original
Gundam is we actually saw a main
character
Amuro we didn't a bloody manual it's not
know getting the cockpit and instantly
can [ __ ] pilot the thing and shoot
everyone like it's nothing that they
actually read off screen right that
would be a plot hole really really this
is your new model oh wow six in it yeah
alarms go off by oh that's it I'm pretty
sure there was a 20-minute break for him
to read the manual oh Gurren Lagann you
know just jump from the cockpit have the
will and you know there you go because
it's the spiral power it just you know
what to do it's in sting it yeah okay
okay cool cool wait wait over my Gurren
Lagann video go in a mold thank you put
logic too much into me it doesn't always
work yeah like with we're long on it's
not about logic it's about motivation
it's about like just like doing the
impossible and that's what I love what
like down life lesson kind of do the
impossible
oh it doesn't make sense logically [ __ ]
logic do it anyway like YouTube is such
a great example and misty your veteran
here on YouTube of course one of the
biggest anime youtubers
you are and you're also a family man a
writer and a gentleman but what I'm
trying to say is YouTube is one of those
things where usually people will tell
you like what the [ __ ] are you doing
like especially as you're starting out
as a small channel like my parents
everyone was like stop waste your time
on YouTube and get a real job buddy like
it's one of those things it's like
you're not gonna make money you know
making videos about cartoons
Internet like what are you thinking him
what but if you have the gurumarga
mentality then you can do it but a lot
of people they don't have the vision
they don't you know they don't think
that way because they're you know they
might love anime they might love YouTube
whatever but they're thinking you know
I've got a I gotta be I gotta go the
safe route I gotta get that nine to five
I can't rely on you know just vision
alone oh that's why I think Graham Hagen
is a great model for life because you
can in fact do the impossible if you
have that vision so usually so you're
saying you can succeed in youtube if you
have the spirit of calm you know is that
what you're trying to say yes which is
why which is why which is why it doesn't
have the spirit of coming up with his
job this incredible discovery Anna Mack
backwards is kameena how a mind blowing
is that no [ __ ] you just realized that
evening yeah misty I go by the name Anna
Mac which is because I basically took
common I and turn around backwards
because that's how much of a fanboy I am
and every second you need the spirit of
Kirito man come on if you guys don't
know if mister you don't know what the
character is kingdom so what isn't your
name khottabych I'm such a huge sa bad
boy the fact everyone makes fun of me
because I like this series so much I
don't care it's just my favorite and I
always do defend it like whatever
somebody says something bad about I
always correct him debate debate with
someone when we're talking about Sao and
he walks in the room we shiver man would
enjoy what I have a filled it with you
buddy it's not even like if you're like
hey I don't you know sort out online
it's whatever I don't like it but Rika
won't be like oh that's cool we'd like
no [ __ ] you bro it's the best you'll get
trigger
so quick it's oh so you're telling me
that he's not ironically liking it he
actually likes it
no he's not Iran he's not ironic oh [ __ ]
feel like he is but he's not he really
really enjoys I'm not I love Sao like
I'm a huge fan boy why you don't know I
have a few Sao potent posters in my room
I have like three figures why why
because I just it's just so good
look Missy the sword of Kirito do you
have this one no I don't have the sword
you know real I sided I said it already
missed the you are his father
you are his father I am NOT somebody's
father not you not you you okay you're
the kid problem with sword online again
I think it's a cool concept I think it's
like even if you like sure at least he's
not a crybaby character there's nothing
any more than cry-baby character so I
can get over at cute oh well there's so
many character and sword online that
have no purpose the girl Google
personalities get out like oh that's not
true every single character in sword
online is it soon today okay look look
at the girl Yui is not but look at the
girl he is not look at the girl who
makes swords in the original Ark and if
she just kind of sticks around no
purpose look at Letha look at this you
know after their particular arks
they doing [ __ ] asana he she's
supposed to be like you're John's
girlfriend and she's just a [ __ ] as
soon as gonna kill on line begins yeah
exactly yeah les she's a damsel in
distress she's just not that useful yeah
to be some lightning sword person or
something yeah I mean you guys haven't
even watch the movie
I have you watched the movie and she was
a damsel in distress there too no she
wasn't was too misty have you watched
the ordinal scale no wait didn't she
need help because she lost our memories
because they took our memories or and
stuff yes great Kirito please save me so
Kirito
misty please watch the movie is it even
out yeah it's coming out on DVDs very
soon okay so all right no no I watched
it in cinemas it was out in Japan no
here in the UK they were showcasing it
cinema really yeah I wanted it but I had
advice I wish I invited solo soul so he
can come with me yeah I'm sure you'll
love that solo movie I've learned from
your video misty on avoiding illegal
sight basically just avoid kiss anime
because they're the ones with the ad
blocker blockers but other than that I
mean a lot of letter sets also do that
it's true man it's insane like it's not
just a bad blocker thing like they might
are you trying to watch legally whenever
I can but there are some animated like
that are older than you can get on DVD
because they're not out or never were
released outside of Japan but whenever
you trying to use these illegal up sites
like you have like eight banner ads and
then twelve pop-ups and then Parco
blocker it's like how can you make so
much money off sticks viruses hmm web
browsers open yeah yeah we've been there
like yeah like they're making so much
money off stuff they don't own like that
is very immoral man to be like yeah it's
horrible
what's funny is the the different you
know methods of the youtubers like misty
made this three-minute honestly pretty
hilarious video about avoiding kiss
anime and then mother's basement goes
crazy like 25 minute rant cursing out
everyone who goes on these sites I mean
I can't mine to be kind of satirical at
the same time inside did you watch that
video I uh which one the mother basement
one yeah a part of it
yeah I know that's all I feel with
mothers based videos I mean he got the
point across like in the first three
minutes and then after dad's just
basically now let's curse a lot fun in
his latest video mother's basement on
Death Note said that in the original
lights downfall is not his hubris and it
would have to elaborate on it but I mean
at this point I was just like what
obviously he guesses he has a god
complex he has a huge you know he
becomes so outside of society doesn't
care about anyone and that ends up being
his downfall I don't know what he's
talking about he just takes it as a
given he doesn't have a god complex they
think that they doesn't hubris is not
the issue and just moves on and I'm like
man but yes that's my that's my little
Rob can I just say one more like little
sentence before we step away from this
political debate that we're having about
other youtubers political recreate errs
is a classic anime walkers gloves you
know it's like Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and re-creators up there
three three episodes in modern classic
brave Misty are you watching me creators
I did not see it entirely I think I saw
this first episode
you should really catch up it's quite
good
so I am I'm almost caught up in like two
to three episodes behind and you
mentioned animatic that your least
favorite characters are the whiny
[ __ ] like Shinji or Yukiteru from
future diary 100% the main guy well I
think that the protagonist from
re-creators takes the cake because he
doesn't even get to the stature of being
a whiny [ __ ] he doesn't have enough
personality to whine he just literally
stands there and does nothing the entire
series aside from mess up yeah and an
awesome politics I'm a few episodes
behind honoree creators like I but I'm
on like 14 or something like that like
so I've seen a bunch of it and I do
enjoy it it has him so cool characters
but yeah the main guys could really use
this it's like why is even here like no
one's being in Christmas anymore like he
caused the hell of a lot of issues like
you have to have a good like a good
leading cast like that's key with some
anime it's really hard to have an anime
that is so good real building and so on
that you can overlook a main character
look at Kona Suba right Kona super has a
solid four main character
and the rest of the world can do
whatever it wants and it'll work out
although although many guman has 0
personality why do people like her all
she does is like explosions and weird
names there's nothing else about her
that's interesting at all you can't name
three personality traits of megami by
the way this is a challenge
darkness best girl but no yeah it's a
challenge it's a challenge man anyone
who wants to say like a chemist come on
knock was useless man no she is not
useful at all she's completely useless
she's the most doesn't matter in the
entire that's that's what that's what
makes her so good is because she's
useless despite being a god like Lucy in
it get useful for some reason so I'm
like yeah she's useless in like dumb and
stuff whether she has a personality like
she's funny I'm not saying you know you
have to love her but she's an
interesting character with mega mean
she's just like like Luca says in the
chat being a Molly is a personality
trait well that's pretty much it she's
the token Molly in the whole story well
you want to know why I think Mega Man is
best girl by Miles and darkness is
literally the worst of the four main
please please
fear yourself prepare yourself so could
you do a separate rant cafe on best
girls yes I want you to now save the
nonsense you're gonna say so I can
destroy you okay fine I would like you
to destroy me
so basically REM is a gram haha Megan is
the only grapes with you but Mega Man is
the only character in the group that is
normal and level-headed throughout the
series unless her really shiny patch
comes along and she decides to blow
something up and now interesting like
darkness is I didn't say she's the most
interesting character I think chasm ax
is the most interesting character the
four
no possibly sons of my sister Kazuma is
just your average guy who actually has a
sense of humor that's basically what he
is but and that's brilliant
he's not your Naruto or your Shiro amia
that's good for the sake of good and
just for the sake of just know a
realistic character with a sarcastic
sense of humor I like him but darkness
is best girl because a she's super hot
and actually developed as a woman be she
is a massacre best girl not best woman
she is a masochist and yet at the same
time she is an honor bound night so for
her man she'll do crazy stuff but she
won't go around doing crazy stuff for
everyone you know so she is clearly best
girl I don't even understand the words
that are community I am gonna flirt with
Knux that definitely is Miss go from
useable I'm changing my mind recon setec
I take it back I said that before I
think of all my streams I did say mega
mean was better than darkness just
because I have three easy words
explosion that is why I suppose the
syllables not words okay okay this three
syllables explosion that's why she's
best girl at all
darkness is how can how can someone like
a masochist how could someone like a
character that could be beaten by a
cabbage to oppose this [ __ ] show to be
honest no it's good it's definitely good
chill show it's not like a sure it's
gonna like wild this makes me think but
it's like a really interesting
entertainer
misty good comedy it's a great comedy
the two episodes I saw the the most can
you make a full statement out of it
because there wasn't enough to entertain
me was it yeah but in two episodes you
haven't seen like the forecast I think
darkness comes in Episode three I will
be honest I think
is a good point you cannot say anything
about that Shawn until you've met my
girl darkness and I think episode where
I did love where that Gollum was like
hitting her and their boobs are jiggling
I mean even now OVA made me feel like I
want to fall asleep it's just our kiss
by the way by the way all these guys
misty think of Emma's best girl in be
zero well I'm gonna melee a man through
and through
I never said Ram his best girl Maurizio
is best girl Amelia is not I miss best
or whatever her name is the girls agree
good misty are you team runner Amelia yo
damn Ram yeah no I think he's saying our
am yeah Ram the pink area oh you know I
always felt bad when I met a convention
and I see like you know two girls one
cosplaying Ram one cosplaying Ram who's
the sad sap that's read the short straw
or the one with the smaller booze I'm
with misty on Ram I think Ram is more
interesting than rem remedy at the
beginning
Ram is actually like a more stable
person whereas Ram is like just like so
insecure and all over the place both
mm-hmm yeah well I don't know what
anyone has to like about Amelia that's
my gripe with it not that Remzi my Z but
I don't like anything right if they
called best girls but but um yeah this
is what happens we have a bunch of dudes
talking about Shawn and anime eventually
just ends up me who's the best girl in
the back remember the stream that we did
remember the river who want the stream
yeah we did know it was us we pretty
sure you don't win streams all the way
my liver wanted in the chat make sure
that somebody's who's reminiscing the
women I have seen D Grayman if I've seen
D Grayman yeah I seen yeah yeah that's
showed enough photos I had some filler
in it but it was okay a lot of filler I
also I agree with that statement
it's it's it's I kind of have mixed
feeling about the agreement I feel like
it's a cool it's a cool concept but
every single character has one of the
weirdest [ __ ] power ever created I'm
not worth the dairy with a giant hammer
but a girl with boots and a guy would it
would a claw do something with that and
then there's lines of time and in
vampire it's a weird [ __ ] match yeah
yeah Bobby is cool though I mean it's
good to be unique in it it is a bit
unique but I think and as they get I
mean usually you have at least one or
two good characters in a cast of shown
in this there really aren't any yeah and
the thing is like in the gray man it's
it's a really dark set up is like people
who are taking the lives and everything
but you hardly ever seen one dies and
the main bad guys a really hilarious
looking creature well I can get behind
that because you want to put someone
that's efficient but also not really
relying on his looks so maybe she get
later on his story's gonna have like
final form the opinion he's gonna know
yeah but I like is designed for let's
say people die but it's just that they
get turned into the demons the Akuma
yeah but it's only the no one dies on
screen we have people that have already
died and turned into heaven but no one
actually even the characters that died
didn't really die and kind of the same
thing in Bleach I mean it started off
being kind of dark with people getting
slaughtered by hollows and everything
and then eventually just just like
everyone's already dead and just have
them fighting each other
yeah so about bleach um I think the
whole thing was basically running off
the soul society arc in the beginning
like from episode 17 to probably 60 70
something you know anything now yeah and
that was a pretty good art we met the
captains we met the lieutenant's Ichigo
got way over
powered in a really short amount of time
and from then on it was just losing
steam because he Rita cute ah I call DG
g oq Tito he go he only kept getting
stronger and more forms and oh there are
hollows now so ichigo's now a Soul
Reaper Anna hollow and a Quincy and it's
a full ring and what and a full bringer
and a full breaker of course which was
dumb as hell that whole hardened that
was a disaster
well the thing is the problem with I
think jeguk made a video about it's like
when you get characters and you keep
bringing stronger enemies you have to
have your main character always go on a
tangent of like increasing power but if
you go at the beginning and you put a
power cap for characters to strive act
then you don't reach that problem no I
think for example you have my hero
academia right exactly that's that's
definitely a game if you give like
someone like all Mike that's already
like the top please the number one and
you strive to reach that then eventually
that's gonna be the the point where it's
gonna end where as the other ones it
kind of always just keep going up and
you reach points where like before
example here's a puto that's a by the
college as far as bleach goes you have
ichigo and he did not even master bankai
yet with a plain sheet guy he beat
kampachi who was fighting at full power
without his eyepatch and everything he
didn't he didn't have no no no he beat
kampachi while ichigo only had his sheet
guy yeah but can patchy didn't have a
bun guy to go so basically ichigo goes
further and then he fights he knew he
tora who destroys ichigo
mmm and then kampachi destroys him so
nobody should go later at that point
ichigo was already weak that was
straight after he just had these fight
with guangzhou yeah straight up he was
equally powerful
week he was early week he was already
I'm Joe I was number six
did you know watch it okay lady he was
being strong class because he was
worried about how a new a saw him so he
took a beating at first because you
scared to show his full power and then
after it was now who convinced her to
like give incentive to Ichigo cuz she
could sense that he was holding back
because of her so then after he starts
fighting seriously
he eventually beat screen-door which you
know going by his mask and everything
he's pretty broken up so a lot of his
powers guns on got about a quarter the
mask left and then after straight after
that mean Tora turns up and he has to
fight him and obviously he just gets
beaten up straight away cuz that goes
right say yeah he was equally strong to
Grimmjow when they fought and and he
knew he taurah is number five and
Grimmjow is number six therefore he knew
he taurah is stronger than Grimmjow and
kampachi who Ichigo beat hundreds of
episodes ago destroyed him
yeah but he trained in the meantime
kampachi did not he said that he trained
you have to keep up with everyone so of
course it would trade off string what do
you mean keep up with everyone
Ichigo jumped to his levels and just
coasted from there he trained with the
captain commander and that's why after
he just sold with two hands cuz normally
he only swings with one hand okay I
could bring more examples if you like
well yeah I think I think the bleach the
bleach fandom can relax personally I
thought that bleach dragged on too long
for certain arcs like the soul society
arc by the time they get to Rukia I was
like come on man come on so that's
that's an issue again with the longer
anime that I have is that they just
think so long to get to the point
all Dragon Ball Z's are good like as a
kid I love them
I realized I'd like to hold fries us all
guys like 90 episodes like not literally
90 but you don't I mean I'm like Jesus
how did I get the thing with bleachers
like was there a need to have like 12
captain's and then each captain like
base a sub captain and then so like
that's already less like 24 characters
did you just drop and I'm like this
there's no point a lot of characters you
don't really they don't have the article
13 they're 13 captain's now yeah well 13
book they're also I wasn't counting like
that they Captain Commander so well he
also had a sub captain yeah so it's
still my point is for anyone who read
the actual manga in Bleach you know poor
poor you yeah the end of the mango is
really bad is really washed all right
and you wanted another example Sol
remember in the beginning of bleach when
a what's the what do they call those
massive hollows the powerful ones shows
up they evacuate the town the Soul
Reaper guys run they're gonna call in
like six captains to take him down do
you remember that was the plan mmm-hmm
skip a few hundred episodes later and
you have two lieutenants taking out
hundreds of men OSes with one swing of
their sword does it rain what do you
mean yeah cuz they trained they were
captains that were immortal for
thousands of years in this whole society
yeah but don't you understand that
Ichigo has a that boosts everyone else
have an aura just so is that say again
you got an aura that boost everyone they
so did you it's a thing you know I think
what you know I think there's one
problem big problem for me with bleach
is that ichigo had no gold it was a
different person that got kidnapped in
every arc that drove him forward yeah
that's why every does every arc felt
like rinse and repeat because there was
no like
end gold in sight you never knew what we
were driving towards it was just like
you know the enemy of the day and
ruski was captured oh no or ehi man was
captured
all Society was captured all story yeah
um speaking of power levels in training
one anime that I am long-running animate
that I am caught up on now is Dragon
Ball super and well I have I have
definitely some issues with it like you
know the super stands from the other
universe all the sudden achieving Super
Saiyan form so easily whereas in our
universe it was taking along stuff like
that
the you know Goku getting shot in the
resurrection ref saga it's like what
anyways
I I do find one thing very interesting
because they screwed up the whole power
level stuff right like they they went to
like universal level and then it's like
where do you go from there they I do it
on multiverse mm-hmm however the power
tournament of power now is very
interesting because they set up these
rules where like you can't fly you can't
use illegal um you know objects for
hundreds of that so it actually forces
them to use strategy over sheer power
yeah and I think that is a very good
thing that they did with Dragon Ball
super is they actually bringing strategy
and teamwork you have to kick the guy
out you can't you know just fly or kill
them or whatever so yeah I thought that
was interesting yeah well that's what
helps their shows is when there's
restrictions over like just who's got
the biggest dick power level training
the more yeah and and that's what's
really cool about one punch man yeah you
can excite them out it's like the tap
and then you got everybody else that you
follow that tries to reach that level
yeah and I love one punch fan because it
I think it's a great comedy enemy I
think like I don't think it's like the
greatest enemy ever but I really enjoyed
because I think it's a great common
enemy it turns that whole troll both
starting off we you can then getting
stronger on its head and I'm really
funny way they say the joke gets old but
personally I very much enjoy it well the
thing is like the whole point of the
show is not to follow side amides to
follow everyone else
yeah like Moomin Ryder bro Moomin Ryder
like him or Jess or you know that
supersonic guy poor Gina sonic well the
way they set the characters in one punch
man
was how Saitama is what everyone dreams
to be and it shows that once you get to
that dream is that really you know what
you want and every other character
represents a different personality
through guys and bad guys and that's
what makes it such a great comedy mm-hmm
how about chuckle get you know soul more
hundred episodes but it's all one punch
man is not even hundred episodes yeah
but I don't want to make fun of anyone
else but yeah one punch man I think is a
really interesting thing and so I come I
did lose one fight guys do you know
against who
listening against the the the guy with
the old guy okay
fly slash mosquito that's how did I know
that that's what you were talking about
but I don't wanna you know draw on for
too long keep you guys for too long
especially misty and soul I know you
guys have families and stuff to take
care of is know if you guys have any
final thoughts please feel free to drop
them here and of course links to
everyone's channel are in the
description guys definitely support our
boys anime recon NOx taco and misty crow
nexia sure yeah I know I know you're
gonna have to get a sub boost from this
stream I appreciate it I appreciate the
shoutout you're welcome
Kristy can we have recon vs. misty
please I wouldn't want to destroy so bad
I mean you want to come back you're
welcome and if one of those facts you
want to do and just go all out on recon
I mean come on misty me and you do top
ten so like brothers come on you gotta
know I'm like heavy leagues in your life
lightly yeah I'm telling you is your
father man you gotta strive to reach you
want even have a Kirito sword why are
you talking you don't have a cute though
well I have three for ease fight with
figurines man you can actually have two
curico swords so I think that that
everyone the the diamond one and the
normal right I have one shatters on that
shield Erica do you know the name of the
sword me elucidate are in dark repulsor
thanks for showing you nice Google
skills night yeah go knocks that we have
for voice actors for board to abridged
on the stream ring oh is that solid
single on believe it or not oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be a hundred episodes until
that bad guy comes again so I we a misty
is a voice actor in Knox's boruto
abridged series so far episode one is
all you can turn down on this channel
episode 2 hopefully sometime this year
right nuts or next yeah well I'm not
animating it yeah I mean well yeah II
guess so edited together and I have a
cameo so you're saying recon has a cameo
- yeah we kind of gave them one word
what what is it what a thing thanks is
that it just you you did it around it
the crab it from DIA the whole video
well I'm definitely looking forward to
that just yeah don't cut recons one word
man I don't when you do the cuts like
don't cut that one word that would son
for him touch on before we call it a
night
for anyone who liked haikyuu and don't
mind reading manga then there is a manga
called shoujo fight which is like a
female volleyball team it's like high
q-- but it's more like focused on the
characters kind of like our first game
is how it's more focused on the
characters than but you might get
impressed
yeah high key word press okay okay a
mighty like so yeah
diamond no ace if I have seen oh that's
a baseball woman yes yeah no III not I
remember seeing that I think maybe a
chapter or so but that was about it
I didn't go back to it when it went like
that it was bad I adopted you just I
didn't go back to it there's lotsa
series I've got like that I never
completed it but I keep getting told
it's amazing it gets better okay okay
all right guys thank you thanks everyone
in the chat for showing up as well and
uh watching pleasure misty thank you for
coming on Michigan animal you guys I'm
sure no but he does top ten lists and
other content some humor some commentary
all that fun stuff so definitely check
him out recon does some reactions you're
gonna love that misty he does some
reactions and he does top ten lists
which are a MV format and good quality
so definitely check him out knocks Taku
does a whole bunch of [ __ ] he does
analysis humor abridged he doesn't even
know what he's doing anymore I think
that's cute I think he's about to start
doing like like Jake Paul videos all
sorts of stuff this tracks all of it and
we got soul maka soul maka does not have
his YouTube channel up and running yet
but he will eventually in his spare time
he is a hentai artist computer lab and
he's also a family man and you can find
him on our discord link in the
description and yeah guys thank you so
much for showing up for grant cafe it
was a pleasure
you're all welcome back any time and
until next time see ya boys no recon I'm
sorry sorry